et caught up with sophie turner at GW
Spri SAG Awards party and we just had to
know more about her role as Jean Grey in
x-men apocalypse
it's the darkest x-men so far definitely
the biggest x-men so far because we have
the most powerful mutant who's ever
lived it's baffling the x-men basically
thing and he he rounds up his his
accomplices and there's a huge huge
battle and it's it's gonna be big and
it's just the origins of like Jean Scott
and storm as well so it's really excited
to see that like tripod come together do
we get to see a young Jean Grey love
connection perhaps there's a little bit
of a love story in it yeah that's like
the third love story in the movie it's
very exciting but just before love
sparks Sophie will return as Sansa Stark
for season six of Game of Thrones it's
gonna be a really big season lots of
characters into like intertwining their
paths and also it feels like this season
the past five seasons everyone was kind
of like spreading out and going their
own direction this season it feels like
people are meeting up and like coming
coming back together feels like people
coming together for a big event and it's
gonna be big I think for blood always
will blow always more blood with this